yeah welcome to this video i'm playing
for zinan and let's see king's indian
goons out the king's indian yeah you can
be sure that i will go forth the doll
line is high five
York we need first is also bitter but
uncommon okay whatever
yeah g-force of course I'm played to
make it more difficult to play a five or
even prevent it all together let's see
maybe I can even play h4 h5 which
completely shuts down his King side
ideas each fire many can play f6 and
even grab porn yeah but okay don't want
to spend spend ages now
I take on g6 what is he doing or maybe
taking on your phone
who
each sixth and probably Bishop f6 and
only move but only a move probably also
a sufficient move
now i'm not sure how to play this it
looks um it's very unclear how to
proceed I can do that with be sugar 6
what do X what is it helping me humming
and yeah I don't like it yeah not sure
something went wrong here
oh this one hmm I didn't expect that
okay let's see to get castled can claim
yeah the age 6 point can easily get lost
him I'm glad that he took them my my
bishop was potentially really bad on d3
so cringy to your why not threatening
kanji seventh oh yeah that I can take a
while rook takes Queen g7 ticks hmm
we'd have a really crazy idea here 95
for this prophet is crazy 95 de 5d6 but
he can take g5
can't wait I have an idea 95 here
we can take with the Rooker I completely
overlook that
ah what the heck what the heck did i do
them what a silly game really mm-hmm and
I Queen have six just Queen f6 yeah
maybe I can hope for a five getting a
five-night be 697 all kinds of all kinds
of stuff it's not really working I can't
need to keep keep the football at least
now it's not not super easy to play I
mean Luke age five black is winning of
course but maybe there's some way to
Terry Tatum check check
455 I'm to just appease it is just a
piece check
time warning no okay white resigns yeah
just a just a very very bad game I mean
from my part all kinds what now okay
some things you cannot see I mean 95 was
really crazy invented it's not working
really it's not working okay but here
it's quite funny here white can win the
game but with a move that it's really
really really really crazy nice white
can oops no I'd check and of course I'm
lost here I just need to play something
else now okay it's just you report
something okay I'm not lost yeah but
okay he can it can get get an excellent
position with rook takes d6 simply but
okay we didn't do that it he went for
that and I wonder thought to show you
this crazy move not this one but night a
for this is actually very strong it
fights again those pieces
yeah this is probably winning if this
bishop moves there's Rock d8 mate almost
made this is also very tricky for black
yeah blackiston in very bad shape here
ok this would have been very lucky there
to to spot this such a move the way it
went down it was it was very unclear the
displays pollicis is still something but
here look g1 is good now yeah it's it's
impossible guys outside the police who
moves on the bot yeah just a bad game by
me but to Ted some fun complications
thanks for watching